unless you've been hiding under a rock
you've probably seen or at least heard
of bird box a conceptual
post-apocalyptic thriller from Netflix
has taken social media by storm sparking
internet memes jokes and even a
potentially dangerous social media
challenge for many viewers the most
interesting aspect of the movie involved
the creatures in the film monsters that
either drive people to kill themselves
or to become fanatics who kill on their
behalf
the mysterious creatures drive people
mad on sight but in the finished movie
they go completely unseen neither bird
box nor the book it's based on ever show
the creatures in physical form only
adding to their mystery now thanks to
creature designer and sculptor Andy Berg
Holtz and special effects studio SFX
Atlas we finally know what bird boxes
monsters would have looked like on the
screen had plans for the movie gone
differently Berg Holtz who is credited
as the special effects makeup lead for
bird box took to Instagram in early
January 2019 to share several pieces of
concept art together the pictures work
to reveal the creature design that the
filmmakers almost used in the final
movie according to Berg Holtz the
intention for the movie was for no two
people to see the creatures in the same
way with their physical forms changing
depending on who is looking at them the
design featured in the photos he shared
is how one of the creatures would have
looked to Sandra Bullock's character
Mallory
the images show a baby-faced monster
with a bulbous vein covered head swollen
ears and a snake-like body meant to be
created using CGI reportedly the
creature is what Mallory would have seen
in a nightmarish dream sequence that was
ultimately scrapped from the final cut
as berg Holtz described it the
custom-made creature design was inspired
by Mallory's pregnancy playing on the
anxieties and fears of an expectant
mother he wrote on Instagram
the producers felt Sandra's nightmare
would have something to do with a
twisted demonic baby creature attacking
her Burr Colts said he designed several
different takes on the monster design
before settling on the final product he
wrote I sculpted at least 3 or 4
variations on the design before it was
approved which began as a more
aggressive monster II look and was
revised to be a bit more subtle in the
end after the release of bird box the
company SFX Atlas also took to Instagram
to share with the monster design might
have
looked like inaction the company's post
shows special-effects artists Stephen
Prouty applying prosthetics and makeup
to actor Dirk Rogers who would have
stood in for the creature during the
shooting of the nightmare sequence
allegedly not everyone who helped create
the designs for the monsters is happy
that their work ended up getting cut
from the movie especially after the film
proved to be so widely seen Howard
burger the co-owner of KNB EFX group
where the designs for the bird box
creatures were crafted seemed to air his
complaints in a sense deleted Instagram
post writing it's always a bit
disappointing when so much effort goes
into something that ends up in the
cutting room floor but I get it and it's
always what is best for the final
product when bird box was released some
viewers found it annoying that the movie
never shows what the monsters actually
look like making the unused creature
effects extra interesting but despite
how unsettling the designs appear some
fans have argued that the decision to
keep the monsters off screen was to the
movies benefit letting viewers come up
with their own interpretations of what
lurks beyond the blindfolds Sandra
Bullock seems to feel the same way
speaking in an interview with horror
movie site Bloody Disgusting Bullock
said she couldn't help but laugh at the
creature in action which she described
as quote a long fat baby turns out the
choice of whether to show the creatures
are not held a lot of importance if
viewer found the monsters funny it could
have ruined the whole film director
susanne bier apparently agreed and
pushed to remove the nightmare moment
from the movie as she put it to Bloody
Disgusting
it so easily becomes funny we actually
shot that scene and spent a lot of
energy on it but every time I saw it I
was like this is not going to be tense
it's just going to be funny
now that the movie is out in the wild
people seem to agree that keeping the
monsters off screen was the right choice
as burg Holtz wrote in his Instagram
post I actually really liked the movie
and think it was better off not showing
the makeup kudos to the director for
sticking to her guns on that one check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about bird
box are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]